it's so lovely to meet you guys I'm so
excited to talk to you because if you
couldn't tell by the outfit this film
was quite formative for me as a as a kid
yes welcome to you too Maggie and you
know you definitely have the goth Vibe
of the vampire so it's greatly in our
demographic Elvira right behind you yes
you're in it awesome thank you well kind
of on the note of this film being really
formative for a generation of horror
fans I was curious if there were any
horror films whether they're vampire
films or otherwise that were kind of
formative for you guys whether it was
growing up like when you made Lost Boys
or that has come out since that has kind
of shaped your understanding of the
genre
well I mean so it's tough to narrow down
but I will say that the omen actually
was is probably one of my favorite uh
horror movies and it was and it was
really I I when I saw it I was like
horror movies can be great you know
they're not just scary they can be great
so I thought it was a great movie and
that sticked on her as well right yeah
absolutely uh for me uh I guess I was a
different story because I was doing a
lot of horror already uh my first
successful film was Friday the 13th you
know where I killed Jason right so that
was that was pretty horrific uh really
um I still have nightmares over that
that scene where he comes through the
window and grabs me
um but yeah I mean it was it was
terrifying as a child uh and then I did
Gremlins right after you know so even
though that had some comedy in it it was
still you know pretty scary I mean I
remember going to the theaters and
always getting creeped out
weird noise when she's coming up the
attic and the stairs and all that you
know thing things have opened just
really creepy stuff uh so it was kind of
like uh you know I enjoyed I I was a fan
of uh of Halloween so I was really big
fan of Michael Myers I loved the pace of
those films the way he walks so slow but
he always seems to catch the things so
scary and kill him uh but so that was
like my thing and then when I got asked
to do Friday 13th I didn't know that it
wasn't the same thing so I I assumed I
was going to be working with Michael
Myers and I was really excited by that
uh and then I found out that no no this
is the guy with the hockey mask oh
hockey mask I have to watch that one so
you know it was interesting learning
about it and then seeing that you know
people on horror movie sets are still
having fun and joking and having a good
time and it's not like you know it's
really not scary you know it's there's
fake blood and it tastes good you can
lick it you know all that kind of stuff
so you know you get used to the idea of
being around it so it was fun yeah and
and kind of on that note similarly to
films like Halloween and Friday the 13th
uh The Lost Boys has kind of has had a a
serious influence on you know
contemporary horror now things coming
out now especially stuff like like
stranger things which even for other
projects you've done Corey like The
Goonies and Stand By Me it kind of is
influenced by the idea of the young set
of kids you know being the heroes not so
much the adult characters and I was
curious for people who grew up kind of
creating that sub-genre what's it like
to watch these things be made now
specifically with such a lens of
nostalgia cast on the 80s is a decade I
mean I think that it you know it's nice
to see the influence first of all I
think I'm very humbled by the fact that
people still care people still remember
the film not only remember the film but
it's always being introduced to new
audiences
um you know we're very lucky that it has
this kind of life extension and we get
to see it you know up close very often
because we do these conventions you know
where we get to meet you know people
from all over the world and they come
dressed up in Cosplay as the Frog
Brothers you know I mean once in a while
you see people dressed as Michael and
you definitely see a few Davids uh but
but overall it's the Frog Brothers you
know that I see more than anything even
Jason Patrick uh brought his kids uh to
a convention and they it was his kid and
the kid's best friend and they're both
wearing headbands and they both got frog
Brothers t-shirts on and he asked if I
would take a picture with him I'm like
of course I would you know it's an honor
and and uh you know we just did this
thing over the summer called Summer of
Santa Carla where it was like they
recreated the boardwalk and they had all
of these you know vendors and stuff so
it was a whole convention literally just
based around Lost Boys very cool you
know kind of like they used to do for
Star Trek but it was like a Lost Boys
convention and we did a concert there
and I've been singing you know people
are restrained I'm sorry I've been
singing Cry Little Sister at my concerts
with film clips and then Jameson came up
and joined me for a few shows where he
actually sent you for a strange with me
all the Frog Brothers together we were
saying people are strange and we're
gonna do it again Dallas Texas on
Halloween night nice I was gonna ask
very briefly um to Pivot to your music a
little bit Corey because you just played
a concert right up the road for me in
Pittsburgh a couple of weeks ago I had a
couple of friends that went yes yeah
yeah I didn't but I had a couple of
friends that came that really loved it
um I was out of town at the time but I
was curious you've put out a couple
singles this year is there anything else
we can kind of look forward to in the
near future well yeah I mean I don't
know if you know but but the singles are
from my new album the new album is
called love left two army with love and
it's all part of a giant box set that we
just put out which actually has uh music
and videos from my like home movies and
stuff like that so the very first music
video that I ever shot which many people
didn't know because I never released it
was during the shooting of Lost Boys so
it all kind of ties together but uh 1986
I directed and starred in this short
film called Runaway and I did all the
music for it and uh we just finally put
it out for the first time so it all kind
of goes back to that time and you know
there was a lot of music that I did
between 86 and 89 people don't realize
so yes the box set is a four CD set two
DVDs a documentary in it it's it's a
great collection hopefully you get a
chance to check it out yeah absolutely I
will I mean I was listening to music
kind of coming up to prep for this so
that'll that'll be really exciting I had
one final question for you guys and it's
kind of a silly question but since in
The Lost Boys you play the Frog Brothers
you play the vampire Hunters I was
curious if you guys had to go up against
kind of any famous vampire in a fight
who do you think you could take on a
beat well uh first of all you know
Jameson and I actually talked about
doing uh a show we were thinking about
the concept anyway of like him and I as
not the Frog Brothers but just as us
going and seeking out you know like uh
real life but yeah real life vampire
lore or or you know other type mystical
creatures and things that we could
actually go and see if they really exist
yeah you know wouldn't it be fun to go
to Transylvania and go to Dracula's
castle and see if we can really find the
vampire uh so you know so like that and
and if we were put into that position
well I suppose we would take our our
Lost Boys frog brother Knowledge and
Skills that we've attained through the
years and I think we do a pretty decent
job yeah and we're not afraid I think
we're ready to face anybody that's right
absolutely not anything right yeah
awesome well thank you guys so much I
really appreciate talking to you I hope
you have a good day thank you